now the health secretary said this week
that the next phase about coronavirus
response will involve test track and
trace we've been talking about it on the
show already mass testing effectively to
find out who has the virus and then
what's known as contact tracing to make
sure people they've come into contact
with can isolate themselves as well now
we can speak to Professor Stefano
Mariano who led one of the earliest
coronavirus contact tracing operations
in the town of tho in northern Italy
thank you for being on the program just
explain what you did we first of all
good morning to you we had the
possibility to test the population of an
entire village near to the Padua
University and was at the village of
above and we have the possibility to
check all the people inside the village
more or less the three thousand people
for many times the first times at the
beginning of the epidemia when we had
the first patient seeker and in that
moment all the people was checked by a
tester and then we check after 15 days
during during when all the people was
the close inside the villager and there
has no possibility to have a contact
with many other people coming from the
other villages and so on so it's a
really a closed population just like I
want to say a social experiment and in
the second test where all the people
were for the second time tested we added
the possibility to study very very fine
the contact between the people and each
people was asked to say where it was
which was the people in contact on whom
where the people lived together and so
on so we we could design a complete map
and to understand that how the virus
spread in the village how was the day
the role of enormous intim attic people
and we are looking now that there is
some people that live with in fact the
people that has no seeker and so we are
starting for the third that the series
of tests that we'll do in the next days
so we will have the third check every
after 15 days a more or less okay and
just did it work environment do you
think it could work in a country as big
as the United Kingdom I think that it's
there are two possibilities to have it
is a checker order to check all the
population with electronic media or with
what they is supposed to do I want to
say with GPS and so on order to use the
technical of the onion-ring when you
have people seeker you have to identify
the first ring the second ring of the
contacts and you have to test that these
people so you can close the contactor
and you have exactly the identification
of the sick people and the isolation of
the people that can be or can could be
in contact with these this man or this
woman and the United Kingdom is said
that it plans to hard team of 18,000
people to do this contact tracing
do you think that's enough yes I think
that it is enough the most important
thing is to test all the people to test
the people seek and to test the people
that live in the neighbors are in the
same flat in the same house and the
people aware where he go every day so it
is not necessary to to test out to check
all the population but is important to
check
to test the people where you are in
contact now - 19 of course is a very new
virus scientists really catching up to
try and find out more about it it's
interesting to hear from you because
really because of what's happening
though it feels like you have a good
picture of what the virus is like and
how apt what can you tell us about it we
have indeed the picture of the virus
were ELISA where is Brad and we we
observed that the most important area
where to check is at the closer
community we we saw that schools
residental for all people and the close
community is the place where we check it
and we found and we trace the more
infected people